con largas filas para votar en los
colegios electorales así empezó la
jornada electoral en perú marcada por el
ausentismo de los ciudadanos elegidos
como miembros de las mesas electorales
el miedo de éstos a contraer el virus en
las mesas hizo que el primer grupo
llamado a votar los vulnerables y
ancianos tuvieran que esperar
largo rato para ejercer su derecho al
voto por lo que el presidente interino
francisco sagasti hizo un llamado a los
peruanos por lo tanto quisiera hacer una
invocación
todos los ciudadanos que han sido
elegidos para ser miembros de mesa para
que vengan a ocupar a cumplir por un
lado con su deber pero también ejercer
su derecho de votación son muchos los
ciudadanos que creen que las elecciones
presidenciales del bicentenario deberían
haber sido pospuestas y comparten el
miedo de los componentes de las mesas
electorales a los que se les prometió la
vacuna antes del día de las elecciones
daines losada me parece completamente
absurda la sopa
el haber hecho hoy día las las
elecciones puesto que los miembros de
mesa no tenían ninguna vacuna entonces
lógicamente ellos tienen familia y
tienen que cuidarse entonces era de
esperarse que muchos no vinieran en
medio de la incertidumbre algunos de los
favoritos de los 18 candidatos que se
presentan a esta primera vuelta fueron a
votar a sus respectivos colegios
mientras otros peruanos hacían fila para
conseguir oxígeno en el momento más
crítico de la pandemia en lugar de ir a
votar además de la crisis sanitaria
el presidente tendrá que enfrentarse a
la recesión económica que la crisis
política en la que está sumido el país
andino